[Musique]
c'est une pièce quand même exceptionnel
puisqu'en fait aller du 16e siècle en
bois polychrome et surtout elle
représente le roi françois 1er en armure
de parade est un tableau de clouer qui
attribua plus et que musée du louvre qui
représente le roi à cheval et l'armure
est vraiment identique c'est à dire que
c'est une armure de parade avec des
mascarons elle est assez maladroite mais
c'est peut-être un artiste local qui a
exécuté cette pièce mais bon on voit
quand même dans les détails de l'armure
ou de l'harnachement du cheval les
choses qui sont quand même assez fines
qu'on retrouve sur ce fameux tableau
[Musique]
tout le cheval on voit un moulin à eau
les moulins à eau c'est vraiment le
symbole de la ville on voit
effectivement la cape rouge avec l'épée
qui va couper le manteau en deux c'est
la représentation traditionnelle de
saint martin on est durant le règne de
françois 1er et le roi c'est un peu le
bienfaiteur de la ville aussi la ville
de romorantin appartient depuis deux
générations sa famille que c'est la
résidence préférée de sa mère enfin bon
la ville est très très lié à françois
1er en son produit est un esprit curieux
ouverts les gens peuvent venir
il se plaint même qu'on lui vole ses
vêtements donc c'est quand même assez
familier il n'y a pas du tout
l'étiquette de courquain louis xiv
faudra mettre en place a rien à voir
il est plutôt bon sens bon il a beaucoup
de conquêtes féminines ça tout le monde
le sait france en premier il mesure 1 m
98 d'un géant dans son époque
[Musique]